you're part of the solution
and and and i i i really want to
emphasize to to young people as much as
possible
look in 08
when i was elected we had the highest
african-american turnout
in history but it was still only
about 60 percent
[Music]
yeah when people say voting doesn't make
a difference
we've never tried what it would look
like if it was 80
voting yeah
or 90 voting
during midterm elections we get 30
percent of people voting
and probably 15 percent of young people
voting
well you you don't know if it's going to
work if you don't try it
so with young people what i i i what i
what i would say to them is look
give this a shot
and if because one thing i can say for
certain
is that after having been in office for
eight years
the country was better than when i came
into office
and i can show that by any measure
so yeah voting worked it didn't
make everything perfect but we solved a
whole lot of problems
and the same is going to be true here
locally in philadelphia
we can make things better and better is
good
i always used to tell my staff you know
nothing wrong with better
[Music]
all right thank you mr president
appreciate you how am i doing on time
here
i wouldn't because i know they're gonna
at some point they're gonna yank me
because that's
i think they're telling me you got one
more question can we get uh
i think they want them young bulls rice
i'll take two all right they got two
knock i'm gonna give it get them out
i'll bring it up you wanna young bulls
he's a state legislator
young boy well michael and let me just
say
if you don't think things have changed
having a brother in the state
legislature with that haircut
that's a change it looks sharp man
but i'm just saying like you know they
you didn't see that
no i would tell you my hair stylist
thanks you and she'll cut this video up
and put it in half
that's good man give me a little props
but again my name is state
representative malcolm kenyatta
and um obviously thank you for
everything you've done and continue to
do
um you're when you ran for office your
slogan
hope and change the last couple of years
have been
a lot of sadness and destruction what
still gives you hope
you know um
when i sort of burst onto the national
scene
it was be it was after i had won the
nomination to be
the u.s senator from illinois and i was
invited to be the keynote
at the democratic national convention in
in boston and
uh i talked about hope and the audacity
of hope in that
and and i made this point about hope
which was hope is not blind optimism
hope is not ignoring problems
hope is
believing in the face of difficulty that
we can overcome and get
a better world hope is looking squarely
at our challenges
and our shortcomings and saying
despite that i think through
effort and will and community
we can make things better
and so i've never lost hope over these
last
four years i've been mad
i've been frustrated
but i haven't lost hope and the reason
is because i never expected
progress to move directly in a straight
line
if you look at the history of this
country you
you make progress and then there's some
back peddling and backlash
and you know you you consolidate some
victories and then there's some slippage
and then you get a renewed surge of
energy and then you
make some more progress and then there's
a little bit of backstepping and then
you
push again and i think what we've seen
over the last four years was
a
in with my election i think we had
probably gotten over optimistic about
how much change had happened in the
country
but that change was real there was some
pushback
and that was real too
but when we started seeing all these
young people from across the country
demonstrating this summer it reminded
you that
they internalize that sense of optimism
and change and possibility
so what gives me optimism is when i see
them i say okay
here we are back to make another push
people like you people like the
councilman
you guys are out there and you're going
to push it to the next phase and then
you're not going to get 100 of what we
need
and there will be some disappointments
and areas where
you fall short and then it'll go back a
little bit and then you push forward
again
so i
one of the benefits of age is realizing
that
in in any endeavor they're going to be
setbacks
they're going to be uh
times where you fall short they're going
to be people who are opposed to trying
to do
the right thing and
the test of
our strength as a people is our ability
to push through that
on through to the next stage
and and i i have never given up that
sense of we are resilient and strong
enough to push through
what we've seen in these last four years
now the question is
making sure that we understand
we can't afford another four years of
this
because what happens is you do get
to a point where you go so far backwards
that it becomes really hard then to dig
yourself out of that hole
and and and i'm so confident in joe
biden and kamala harris
surrounding themselves with people who
are serious who know what they're doing
who are representative of all people not
just some people
and us being able to then dig ourselves
out of this hole
and we're in a deep one you know you you
talk about let's say the pandemic
the pandemic would have been tough for
any president
i mean this is a we haven't seen
something like this for a hundred years
but the degree of incompetence
and misinformation
the number of people who might not have
died
had we just done the basics
the degree to which it has impacted
low-income communities so
disproportionately
that's something that i'm i'm not just
con
i'm not just confident that it can be
fixed
there's proof
[Music]
canada right across the border
you've got 39 percent
fewer deaths
almost 40 percent
i mean we have examples
so so i
knowing joe as well as i do knowing
kamala as well as i do
knowing the people that they're advising
them i know we will
be able to deal with this pandemic more
effectively
it doesn't mean that it's all going to
be solved tomorrow
we're still going to have some struggles
but i know we can do better
and and that's what gives me confidence
that's what gives me hope but we're
going to have to vote
in order for that to happen all right
last question that's something yeah
thank you mr president i was just
supposed to introduce you and tell me
i'll go ahead
thank you
thank you
goodness back on next week what about
you thank you
gotta stay